[Music]
[Applause]
Scott wolf he's been covering USC for
over 25 years reporter for inside USC
blog and caught my attention with this
story uh yesterday and I had speculated
this on the preseason I had no
information no inside information other
than is Lincoln Riley putting out
feelers to take a job in the NFL next
season maybe a package deal with Caleb
Williams and that's what Scott uh wrote
yesterday the word is Riley would be
open to an NFL job if he could follow
Caleb Williams and uh if the Bears had
the number one pick in the draft let's
bring in Scott now Scott how real is
this well I think it's you know coaches
are notorious gossips which is why I
love coaches so I've heard this from
three different NFL coaches that they've
heard he's putting out feelers to NFL
teams that he's ready to jump if it's
the right scenario which means he wants
to go somewhere with Caleb
Williams uh you know presumably the
number one pick in the draft so it' be
the team that had the top pick or traded
for the top pick and that would be the
ticket uh to the NFL and and if you
listen to him talk the last couple
months he keeps saying I only want to
coach till I'm 50 which would be 10
years so
this would probably be a time to think
about jumping to the NFL if if he wants
to do it just a coincidence that this
comes out after the bad lost to Notre
day uh yeah I actually heard it uh last
week before the game and I I waited to
kind of talk to a couple other people
because I didn't want to just write it
without kind of getting it from other
sources and uh I I do sense though you
know the loss kind of magnifies the
situation a little bit because think he
is getting a little frustrated right now
because there is a lot of criticism in
LA with the team the way it looks that
you know for two years they've been
talking about the horrible defense and
his lack of a defensive coordinator and
all that stuff I think kind of wears on
him and he's looking at life without
Caleb Williams so I think it's something
he's pondering yeah I think that that
Notre Dame loss kind of illuminated what
people were afraid to say and that is
USC is not a great team even very good
and maybe some maybe not even a good
team I think that Caleb has kind of
covered up a lot of things here and if
you look around the Pack 12 got some
pretty good teams there and I don't is
this a a rebuild USC situation do you
think let's say Caleb leaves when he
leaves and Lincoln Riley stays are they
reloading or
rebuilding well to me the big question
is does Alex Grinch come back if Lincoln
Riley stays I I think he needs a
top-notch defensive coordinator and he's
resisted that his whole career you know
he's a Mike Leech disciple these guys
don't know any defensive coaches they
don't care about defense it almost seems
like and and like you said Caleb
Williams is an eraser he erased all
their problems and I I feel like a
broken record talking about you know the
cornerbacks the offensive line the
scheme on defense so I don't know how
much he can fix those things um you know
we we we can call it a rebuild but he's
gone so aggressive in the transfer
portal yeah I don't know how much more
he can do in the transfer portal for
next year what do you make of the story
that's resurfaced that Caleb Williams is
his reps are telling teams or agents uh
to tell teams that he wants a piece of
the team if uh he goes there I think
that's farsal to be honest with you I
mean a a rookie coming in and saying he
wants a piece of the team who hasn't
even proven himself I mean is he going
to show the game tape of the Notre Dame
game when he makes this pitch to get a
piece of the team I mean an NFL owner I
think would just laugh at such a
prospect and you know I don't know that
he's actually said that there I saw the
report that he did and you know he's
he's welcome to ask for anything he
wants but we're talking about the NFL
here I mean give me a break that a
rookie is g to come in and get a piece
of the team but what what kind of advice
is he getting because you can't do this
legally you can't get a piece of the
team cuz you could circumvent the salary
cap I could give uh Patrick Mahomes a
million dollars in a piece of the team
therefore I don't have to give him you
know $55 million I can use that money
elsewhere so it it is farcical that you
would even ask that question because it
it's illegal it's against the CBA so I
that's why I don't know if he's being
sabotaged here it just feels like it's
uh people might start to pile on Caleb
Williams a little bit well you know
anybody could say it because he's like a
conglomerate at this point even though
he's in college with all his endorsement
deals and his management and you know
his father obviously is a very big
influence and he's already talked
publicly about you know we have to go to
the worst team in the NFL if he's the
number one pick and that's not really
ideal blah blah blah so I I think all
this stuff at the end of the day he's
gonna go as a number one pick wherever
he's picked and that's the end of the
story because I I look him and he looks
a little jaded to me this year and and I
think he's kind of uh frustrated and and
just want to I want to add something to
this you know idea he would go with
Riley it at the Arizona State game he
was waving uh Riley off during the game
when Riley was trying to Signal him to
change plays so I'm not even sure that
deep down he wants to play withy you
know what Scott He if if I'm correct
with this that it felt like Lincoln
Riley was pointing fingers said Caleb
Williams missing wide openen receivers
when he threw those three interceptions
against Notre
Dame yeah that's something you know we
haven't seen in La as uh from linoln
Riley because they've been successful
but it looks like when they lose or
struggle he kind of points the fingers
at the players and it finally got around
Caleb Williams became the focal point of
that criticism after the game Saturday
and that's something you haven't seen
out of him because he hasn't had to
criticize him but uh
you're seeing I think a frame around the
edges of the program right now because
they're dealing with adversity for the
first time and it's only been one loss
what happens when they play Oregon
Washington you know UCLA they gotta play
Utah this Saturday so uh everybody's
kind of holding their breath to see how
the last five games are going to go is
Lincoln Riley the head coach at USC next
year that's a hard question um I I
suspect he will be back just just
because I'm not sure an NFL team is
going to want him and and what I've
heard is if they did want him they would
order him to hire a defensive
coordinator that they want and defensive
coaches that they want and I don't know
if he's ready to give up that power so I
don't know if he's ready to make that
big leap right now but hey if the
Chicago Bears came I'm sure he' try to
go Scott good to talk to you thanks for
joining us anytime Dan Scott wolf
reporter for side USC blog he's been
covering USC for 25 years now